all right so our next
speaker
codes but he only codes to death
metal please welcome
Paul so the time it took oh thank you
thank you thank you for having me
organizers I really appreciate it um
this is more of an academic thing when
you're you're speaking to a room full of
medical doctors and conflict of interest
is a big thing I only have one Financial
disclosure and that's I'm founder and
owner of data science recruiting company
called Talent seek uh but that's not
relevant here because none of this work
or my clients had anything to do with
this
presentation uh okay with that said uh
the time it took for me to get up here
uh fiddle with the display get the
PowerPoint fixed uh somebody just died
from cancer it's about one person a
minute or about 1500 roughly every
single day right um people are coming
down with cancer from many different dis
um sites of their body and uh I'm hoping
to leave you with um uh this idea that
cancer like many diseases is a disease
of numbers and with those numbers comes
data and data that we can mine and try
to better understand
cancer so for example uh 3.2 billion is
how many base pairs or sets of genetic
letters that we have in the human
genome these letters are organized into
about 20,000 genes and this is kind of
misleading because those genes can
actually be combined in different ways
to give rise to anywhere from 250 to a
million different proteins right these
are like the workhorses of
ourselves our DNA is about
99.6% similar to one another's but that
remaining 4% that's about 12 million
base pairs right this is where side
effects from medication come this is
where predisposition the certain types
of cancer comes from and it's in in
those
differences and we're getting smaller
here here right so uh six so how many
feet long the DNA for one of your cells
would be if you uncoiled it and put it
end to end right but that's just one
cell some estimates we have trillions of
cells so if you put all of them together
that chain would be about 67 billion
miles
long um where does all this fit right we
have these little cells well this is in
a cell and if you were to take a human
hair slice it length uh lengthwise 10
times that one slice would be about as
big around as as the
nucleus and even smaller yet is the
error rate for duplicating this DNA so
the these letters as yourself
divide now this this rate this error
rate doesn't seem like a big deal until
you consider all what I just told you
and how much DNA each cell has right so
that's actually about 120,000 mistakes
every time it cell divides and they're
dividing all of the
time if you have a m akake in these
letters right it can lead to a very
different message so you you have the
innocuous statement oh let's eat grandma
or something a little bit more Grim like
let's eat Grandma right so punctuation
matters like the letters these context
it really
matters most of the time these mistakes
are harmless and uh we have cellular
Machinery that actually catches them and
can actually repair uh these mistakes
but not all mistakes are cut and even if
we have one mistake you know it's it's
perfectly fine but a second mistake a
third mistake eventually there's a
snowballing and eventually you end up
with with cancer if you can actually see
oh my mouse is kind of hard to see you
end up with
cancer so in order to speak about this
we have to talk a little bit about the
central dogma of biology I've already
mentioned cells and genes and proteins
um the DNA is our blueprint right so
these are um nucleotides and they make
up what what I like to think of as like
the cookbook or or the blueprint so so
DNA is like the cookbook we have these
other molecules called RNA and that's
like the recipe so you open up the
cookbook you flip to a certain page and
say oh man I really feel like um vegan
vegan pizza tonight so I'm going to find
that recipe and then when we actually go
you bake it in the oven and you cook it
that's kind of an analogy for the the
protein so you have this
blueprint your cells make a message from
this blueprint and then they create
related proteins that actually caring
out the the actions in this case it's
it's in this in our analogy it's it's
the
dish there's a variety of different
Technologies for measuring the mistakes
of the cookbook the recipe the the dish
or even I don't know the metabolites
which is more like kind of like what you
sprinkle on top of right the the
acuta um all these different
Technologies give rise to um lots and
lots and lots and lots of data
particularly big molecular data so a lot
of times people in healthcare they think
of of Big Data um e EHR I know I know
somebody who's working on millions of of
of patient records right at this moment
uh I work on the molecular side and the
molecular side the clinical side is also
important too right all of this data is
like the big data of of cancer it's it's
important because it can tell us things
about the treatments that work best for
people right but everybody is a little
bit different as I mentioned before so
not all treatments even if it appears to
be the same kind of cancer is going to
work in the same way um identifying uh
folks for clinical trials um even
developing new treatments or or cure um
this is a bit of an old infographic I
think it's from 2015 but it's it's a
great Point too where it talks about
some of the how much money goes into the
cancer research and also that most of
these cancer uh treatments do not
work uh I'm a I'm a bioinformatician or
really it's just a fancy word for a
biological data scientist so uh I try to
make sense and my research program at
the MAF Cancer Center is making sense of
big molecular data I sit at the
intersection of bunch of different
fields as you can see here and in many
ways we're kind of jacks of all trades
or we're like kind of a mile wide inch
deep in some cases and so I have a
mathematics and a chemistry background
right so I'm kind of well suited to sit
at the intersection of all these
different fields but I am not like a
super expert on machine learning or even
like computer science but I do
understand the biology and I'm dangerous
enough with my code where we can use
data science approaches to try to
understand
cancer uh this brings us to the the
systems approach uh so many Labs even at
mafit um they you know they make their
their whole careers out of studying a
single molecule a single Gene a single
protein um generally as
bioinformaticians that's not what we do
we're interested in the systems level so
not just one one gene in a patient what
what's happening with all of the genes
and how are they working
together um us to understanding that the
two main goals of cancer research um so
if we understand what's going on in a
patient's cells we're able to say
compare someone who's sick to someone
who's healthy and try to understand okay
well what is different about them why
did they get cancer what are these
mutations that are giving rise to the to
the cancer if we can know that then we
can develop new treatments for cancer um
treatments for cancer historically have
tended to be very bad right so you have
chemotherapy for example where it's it's
a poison and you take it or patient it's
is infused right intravenously they're
infused with it their their hair falls
out uh they get very sick you're
basically poisoning your body um you're
poisoning the cancer a little bit more
because these are rapidly dividing cells
they're a little bit more susceptible to
chemotherapy but you're still hurting
the patient what if we can understand
what is making this tumor tick B based
on that simple comparison that I gave
you can we find a silver bullet such
that we can treat that specific molecule
that specific condition within the tumor
but leave the patient's body otherwise
untouched so finding new drug targets is
one of the main goals uh the other is
early detection biomarkers right so for
a lot of cancers even to this day uh
there are no biomarkers right so you go
to the doctor for your annual checkup
they may draw some blood you peen a cup
and you know they're looking for
elevated uh glucose levels and
cholesterol these are biomarkers for how
healthy you are um for the most part
there are no biomarkers for cancer so
you can't just go pee in a cup and the
doctor says oh hey this this looks a
little off we should do some more
testing for the excuse me for the most
part uh that does not that does not
exist and the earlier that you catch
cancer the better the patient does right
so regardless of of where it where it
originates so using these tools that we
have um at this this intersection of
this V diagram and using systems
approaches to try to get to New Drug
targets or early detection
biomarkers um in a paper that we
published now a couple years ago we were
trying to squa cell lung cancer um Squam
cell lung cancer uh is the second
largest subtype of non- small cell lung
cancer right so when you talk about lung
cancer there's actually a variety of
different types of cancer that you can
get uh s cell lung cancer in particular
um uh Fair has a fairly High rate
compared to some of uh the other cancers
and it is traditionally thought of as as
a smoking Associated
disease if you sort of lose the genetic
Lottery and or you're a heavy smoker and
you get squamous cell lung cancer you
have limited treatment
options uh for some patients where their
tum uh they develop cancer um there is
something called a driver mutation right
so that error that I was talking about
before in the DNA uh it occurs a lot so
there are common mutations that show up
in a lot of patients uh doctors and
research res archers have figured out
that some of those make a protein that
you can treat with a drug but you know
these patients with this particular
mutation that makes a particular mutated
protein is the vast minority of cases
right so again we need to understand
this disease better in order to get to
better better treatment better early
detection
biomarkers so uh people knew about sell
lung cancer they even had some idea
about the molecular underpinnings of
this disease uh but we wanted to do a
systems level multi I approach to
profile these tumors and really get to
what is going on with them and to
understand them such that we can get to
treatments and biomarkers uh this is the
cohort that we used um it was
predominantly older uh predominantly
Caucasian smokers and uh on the right
hand side here is a little bit about the
the methodology and the experiments that
that we did and then so we take U at
Moffet right we're a research hospit
we're a research institute and a
hospital so the patients that come in
they are uh most of the time consented
saying hey if we take your tumor out can
we please keep it and use it for for
research uh so we identified 108 cases
of scus of lung cancer um we took um
essentially the surgeon takes this out
of the patient and they just drop it
into liquid nitrogen to preserve it such
that it is preserved and we can look at
things like DNA and RNA and proteins um
the pathologist also needs to look at it
so they also take a piece of this tumor
take a microscopically thin slice of it
put it under a microscope so that way
the path ologist can look at it and say
oh this is stage one or stage two or is
this kind of cancer Etc and then so with
this with this cohort um we subjected
them to um uh targeted DNA sequencing
RNA sequencing uh copy number array uh
analysis or copy number variation
analysis which is actually counting how
many genes you can get extra copies of
genes which also can drive cancer um AR
sequencing and also uh proteomics which
is what my lab specializes in so this is
looking at uh large scale protein
expression in tumors right you can DNA
you can look at RNA you can look at
protein my lab specializes a lot in the
protein but then also systems level how
does all of this interact and work
together uh oh and I I already kind of
it would have been a nicer figure I
guess to have up here but yeah so we're
doing a systems approach where we're
going to take the DNA from these
patients take the RNA from these
patients take the protein from these
patients excuse me they're tumors
specifically and profile them to
understand the Inplay and can we get to
new treatments early detection
biomarkers so a big problem with cancer
research is just like how on Earth do we
classify these patients right we have
some patients uh we have some data
associated with them maybe we've
extracted DNA or RNA or protein but like
what does it mean and how does it fit
together U so one thing that we can do
is we can just cluster our data um I
mentioned we did a proteomics
experiments right this is large scale
Global characterization of the proteins
that are in tumors um these experiments
identify over ,000 proteins and it's
across 108 patients well that's that's a
matrix right we've got a matrix of
features we have Columns of of samples
um uh or tumors in this case uh we can
do something like consensus clustering
which is just a cluster of clusters
approached to try to get at what are my
inherent groupings within this cohort of
108 samples because I don't know what
they are I I know I know they most are
stage one some are stage two some are
stage three they're mostly white but at
the molecular level what does this look
like and what can this tell us about
treatment or early detection biomarkers
um so we can do things like consensus
clustering and right picking a k right
so everybody dos it's kind of hard to
pick well if we're going to do
supervised clustering what K do we pick
and then so you have metrics that you
can apply here just like you can with
most data um to understand what K what
are my groupings what are my numbers of
clusters and then so with our protein
data right we have lots of data but the
protein level data we're going to
Cluster them uh we have some of these
metrics we can say oh yeah kind of the
graph kind of bottoms out around five
this looks like it's converging we can
call it five clusters and we can look at
the tracking plot we can look at the
group membership for different CES for a
particular patient sample and understand
is its classification is it cluster
relatively stable relative to the others
or is it moving around the lot because
if it's moving around the lot and it's
not stable maybe that's not a great K to
pick so we take this we say okay it kind
of looks like five groups but this is
just the protein data right so we're
doing a systems level approach we're
going to integrate this with all of the
other data that I had and it leads to
something like this and I like to refer
to this as the million dollar figure
right not only because it's kind of
pretty but it also cost a million
dollars right between all of the the
processing and paying you know paying
for the surgeon paying for the sample
collection paying for the DNA extraction
the RNA of the protein having the
analysts I I led the work on this
putting it all together figuring out
what it means it it's like a million
bucks right um
uh our findings were at least here I'm
going to kind of handwave and summarize
a bit but those five clusters actually
two of them and two of them actually
seemed pretty similar so you can see the
green bar uh across the top uh we
identified um three subtypes of Squam
cell lung cancer based on clustering and
then we can right so this this is a
protein level heat map we can see the
grouping on top but then we can overlay
all this other data that we have to
annotate these samples and really
understand what is on with them and okay
we cluster them and they behave one way
but what mutations do they have what
does the RNA look like and we can you
know do multiomic multi-layered
experiments or analyses to try to
interrogate and understand the
data uh one particular um one particular
finding was this inflamed subtype and uh
we wanted to understand what is going on
inside of these tumors these tumors were
inflamed right so like they're they're
irritated they're immune Rich So based
on the signals from the protein the
signals from the RNA lots of signals
that we're receiving and all of the data
it says that these samples are immune
rich but there's right thousands and
thousands of proteins some are going up
some are going down how do we make sense
of all of this data I'm no expert I
don't have all 20,000 genes or proteins
memorized right so we have these tools
um uh called pathway enrichment tools or
we can perform pathway enrichment
analysis where we take a big huge list
of features maybe you a thousand
different proteins that are elevated in
this inflamed subtype that we've
identified and we can condense them down
into only a couple of Pathways right so
this is a consolidation of information
Dimension reduction and we go from Whole
huge list of features in this case
proteins to a much smaller list of
Pathways or the biological processes
that this cancer cell is
using so when we do a pathway enrichment
of the inflamed subtype we see on the
right hand side here these blue bars
right there's a a p Val adjusted P value
on the on the x- axis but this is
shouting out to us hey these are
inflamed tumors there is increased
immune response um from these different
Pathways so each one of these bars is a
different pathway which has some
proteins inside of it right we're
consolidating the information together
and so this is screaming
immune but there's there's a problem
right so I mentioned that we took all
these tumors we ground them up we're
actually don't know exactly what's
inside the tumor there's going to be
some cancer cells but there's also going
to be a whole bunch of immune cells um
these immune cells are critically
important because there are new
immunotherapies that are available that
essentially take the breakes off of your
immune system and allow you to uh treat
a patient and then their own immune
system can attack the cancer so uh a
fundamental question that we have is
well what is inside of this tumor what
immune cells make it up because that's
critically important to uh
immunotherapies and these
treatments so uh some clever person said
hey well if we have this tumor and it's
a whole mixture of cells we can actually
just model this if we just assume this
tumor right it's some cancer cells and
some immune cells and some end
endothelial cells like blood vessel
cells so we have a whole bunch of
signals that are summing up to this
mixture if we can go independently
isolate some cancer cells and some te-
cells and some B cells some various
immune cells endothelial cells we can
derive a signature so then the mixture
on the left is what we've measured that
is is known the signature is measured
now that is known the only thing that we
don't know is how these are combining to
make the mixture it's just it's a linear
algebra problem right so we have these
immun deconvolution tools which given
some sequencing data we can we can throw
it into the algorithm and get back out
how many cells or what are the relative
populations of some of these cells and
that looks like like this so we've just
done a simple box plot I'm using
nonparametric statistics to compare the
levels of these scores that we're
getting out of the deconvolution
algorithm and again all these different
immune cells that we have they're
they're elevated or at least the
neutrophils the memory B cells the
monocytes were were all elevated and we
can I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
we can actually see this so if right
we've been just grinding up these tumors
I was telling you we've lost that
resolution but we have samples left over
we can go back to these patients cut new
slides put them under a microscope and
stain them and ask the question do we
see these immune cells that all of our
omix Technologies are pointing to so
I've circled some regions here that are
um essentially immune hot and what we
can do is go and this is a very zoomed
in picture of um some of these immune
structures that we observed in the cells
so these are cells underneath the
microscope inside of a tumor that have
been uh stained with a Amino florescent
um tags to light up the different
populations of immune cells and do you
recognize the problem here it's like
like I'm just grinding all these up
together and then when I measure it it's
just everything kind of mixed together
there's spatial data here these
individual cells are relating to one
another the next layer sort of the next
big thing in the work that I do are
spatial analyses and single cell
analyses so instead of looking at the
tumor as a whole now you're getting down
to the individual level but then it's
like an exponentially increasing uh uh
exponentially more data um real quick
plug CU I'm out of time uh MAF Cancer
Center uh we run a biod DAT club uh we
have funding through the r Consortium
and it's kind of like a monthly R Meetup
but we also talk about uh a bunch of uh
different languages and libraries and
this was very much built as we get a lot
of scientific talks at mafit and it's
just like I don't want to see another
talk I want to actually know like how do
you run these packages that that you're
talking about or like what goes into
doing some of these analyses and it's
got a heavy um like molecular heavy
Health informatics slant to it but all
are welcome and we have Meetup Group um
if if you're interested we're going to
have a hack cancer hackathon in February
and these are just acknowledgement
slides so I have funding through the
Cancer Research Institute which is a
foundation that's funding some of those
pretty pictures that I just showed you
and I've I've had funding from the
National Institutes of Health from mafit
our department funds pilot projects uh
and others thank you so
[Applause]
much